it's been roughly three weeks since the
launch of the CS2 Beta And while some
streamers are having the time of their
lives a lot of people are getting sick
and tired of just ripping dust to over
and over and having to wait ridiculous
queue times to do so top of that there's
a lot of Die Hard fans that are really
upset that they still don't have access
so did valve kind of screw this up dude
there's the oh
there's not a single player in Death
Match not one person in death match
foreign
possibly one of the greatest FPS maps of
all time that being said three weeks of
it and things are getting a little bit
dull now imagine it's your job to cover
everything CS2 but you don't even have
access to it so you're just stuck here
watching the same creators play the same
map over and over and over again alas
I'm not the only one a little bit
frustrated about the whole Limited Test
situation Dimitri other creators some of
you are all feeling a little bit let
down by Valve and those who do have
access are quite reasonably getting
bored of queuing for dust too the
question is is any of this
disappointment Justified well to get
that answer it's important to know that
the beta controversies actually go all
the way back to the first few days of
its release everyone knew that whenever
valve made the announcement of a new CS
one thing was going to be on everyone's
mind when and how the hell do I get to
play and as we covered back then valve
stated that entrance into the Limited
Test was determined by things like
Recent Play Time and Trust Factor but
just hours into the Beta it was clear
that that wasn't exactly the case now
people were probably expecting to see a
ton of content creators and Pros get
access but CS go Fanatics seeing
valorant streamers get access that rubs
some people the wrong way yo yo yo
Dennis do you actually get it yes
look
now as much as I hate to be that guy I
do understand both sides on one hand I
am still one of the many malding outside
the club and the CS2 announcement was a
gaming phenomenon so I can understand
people getting pissed off for not
getting access when they've supported
the franchise for over a decade on the
other hand it does make sense for valve
to include valid streamers in the beta
listen they know every CS go player is
going to want to play CS2 regardless but
Riot is their biggest competitor and
they want to reach that audience next to
that valve technically said that there
were other factors that got people into
the Beta they just decided to not
elaborate on what those were did they
lie
not really is it shitty
probably but this is valve they've never
given a flying I'm here to tell you
right now
now eventually most large voices in the
community did make it into the Beta but
that's when the community's feelings
towards the whole CS2 announcement got a
bit more complicated after three weeks
people who were in the beta were getting
bored of playing dust 2 Non-Stop and as
a result we saw plenty of complaints as
well as a drop in the player account I'm
serious if you go on Twitter you're
going to find people saying that CS2 is
already dead and it hasn't even been
born yet but then there are those who
didn't get into the Beta and would sell
a kidney to play Dust too and they think
that streamers are just being a little
ungrateful and honestly I feel like the
frustration is at least kind of valid
outside of a few content creators I
don't know a single person who's been
invited to the beta and that includes 12
000 hour Global Elites but it seemed
like if you were a big enough content
creator and asked politely enough you
and all your pals could get in so on one
side you have people that are bored of
the beta and on the other you have
people that are upset that they can't
even get in to make matters worse with
people who have access dropping like
flies means that queue times are going
through the roof one person had to wait
over 48 minutes four does just two it
feels like valve tried to disguise a
Creator event as a beta test because
they knew they couldn't keep it from
leaking but then failed to do either
don't get me wrong I still believe in
the hype and Trust the process but I
can't help but think that this could
have gone a bit better I mean just look
at the Valiant beta back in 2020. sure
the twitch drops method was a show
and the game had its own problems but at
least it was simple for the general
public to get in and once they did there
was plenty of content with that
comparison alone I feel like valve
should have just waited another month or
two and dropped a more significant beta
or at the very least communicate to the
fans on exactly what was going to be
included in the beta and who was going
to get access to it but as per usual
it's been radio Silence from valve I
mean everything we have learned about
the game since valve's initial drop new
Cosmetics back live emotes has
been from Data Mining and leaks now I
know I know we should all be used to
valve's lack of communication by now but
I honestly can't help but feel that this
could have gone a lot smoother now
obviously valve is not going to stay
silent forever but the question is are
they going to crack this puppy open or
if you're just going to get small drops
of content here and there My Hope Is by
Thursday of next week we will have our
answer and I'm sure this is going to age
very well with that said I'm curious as
to what you all think I know beta
testing is extremely important and
difficult but do you think valve should
have waited until they had more to offer
and two more people or do you think
we're all just a bunch of entitled
babies because honestly that's a fair
conclusion as well and I'm not sure what
camp I'm in either to be honest with
that said
stay safe Gamers and I'll see you on the
next one
do you guys ever play Gary's mod a lot
of people don't for some reason don't
know about it but there's a second
Gary's Mod coming out that's with Source
two I've been trying to get into that
like more due diligently than CS2 I
think that's like the only game I have
more hours in than Counter-Strike it's a
fantastic game I haven't played the uh
the remastered version yet though